the predator was directed by Shane black
and is the official sequel to the other
predator films it does actually
acknowledge predator one and two it's
not a reboot as some people feared this
is definitely a continuation of the
franchise it doesn't erase anything it's
just its own film as I'm sure a lot of
you know Shane Black was actually in the
first predator film playing the
character Hawkins this film was
something I was really looking forward
to I'm a massive fan of predator I've
loved it my whole life
it's suspenseful it's gritty John
McTiernan directed the shit out of that
movie and Arnold was actually really
good in it and I love Shane Black's this
was a great combination of so many
things coming together and I could not
wait to see this film it's easily one of
the most disappointing movies of the
year by far there are so many things in
this film that I just don't understand
the plot is that a young boy played by
Jacob Tremblay accidentally triggers the
return of predators to earth by having
some of their technology he presses some
buttons and then all of a sudden there's
a little battle going on in their town
his estranged father is a soldier and
him and his team of wacky goons decide
to fight against the Predators I cannot
believe how many bad choices this film
made it's honestly kind of a comedy on
purpose not even unintentional there's
barely a suspenseful scene I think
there's maybe one suspenseful scene in
the entire film it's Olivia Munn's
character she has to go through this
decontamination process and to do so she
has to take off her clothes because this
door will not unlock unless she
decontaminates herself all the while
there's a predator wreaking havoc in the
next room coming closer and closer to
her as she has to go through this
process to get this door to unlock it's
probably the most suspenseful scene in
the movie and really the only
suspenseful scene in the movie this
movie is just obsessed with quips and
one-liners and the first predator has a
lot of those I mean if it bleeds we can
kill it
you know we've seen predator a billion
times and we've heard the great lines
from all these characters but in this
film it tries to do that it tries to
create another team of ragtag soldiers
that are macho and put out cigarettes on
their tongue and things like that you
meet them all on a bus and they all have
a quirk and that's about it
it's really hard to get attached to any
of them it's really hard to care about
their plight because they're just
constantly joking they never seem like
they're actually afraid one of the best
parts of the first predator is that
these hardened macho guys that go into
those woods with like I got time to
bleed oh really
you got time to duck like those
characters are terrified within 20 to 30
minutes of being in that jungle in this
film they never seem afraid they just
seem very excited to fight the predator
and the SuperDuper predator and the
predator dog and all the other stupid
things this film comes up with in the
final few minutes i sat in complete
disbelief at just how much of a disaster
this film actually is as a huge fan of
Shane Black is a huge fan of the
predator franchise
I am massively disappointed characters
who have never murdered someone in their
entire life do in this film and don't
show a hint of sadness or remorse yeah
sure they're in a life-and-death
situation but you think for a second
some of them would sit down and be like
oh shit I just took someone's life but
no that never really happens there are a
few good things to the film I'm not
gonna sit here and completely trash it
the predator like the normal classic
predator great costume really really
fantastic work the actors have nice
charisma and some of them are funny shit
I guess that's it just like in predators
Alan Silvestri's themes are being reused
this time by henry jackman it confuses
me why they didn't just hire alan
silvestri again i mean maybe he didn't
want to do it or he wasn't available
also I mean what's John McTiernan up to
nowadays he's free get him to direct
this like I mean there's so many choices
that seem like they should have been
made but they just weren't made and it
really boggles my mind that with an
unlimited budget and all of his talent
this is what Shane Black made it's just
a funny cringy CGI fest with a few
predators it's it's easily the worst
predator movie excluding the AVP films
but to be honest I actually like the
first
b.p more than this that's kind of sad
but by far the worst thing about the
film is that it does not feel like it
has a cohesive narrative scene after
scene it feels like stitched together
moments where tons of things have been
cut out or reshot or changed or altered
and it doesn't feel like the film flows
naturally it doesn't feel like there's a
progression of events it just feels like
here's a scene make a few one-liners oh
shit there's a predator
let's joke about it because apparently
seeing a gigantic alien is really funny
this film was a mess and easily the most
disappointing film of the whole year I'm
gonna give the predator a d-plus man
this has not been the greatest year for
films there have been some really
entertaining movies fall out searching
recently thank you guys so much as
always for watching look forward to more
reviews very soon I have a few things I
want to still see this weekend and a
video game that I'm playing right now
that I am truly loving and I can't wait
to share that with you guys thank you
guys so much as always for watching and
if you like this you can click right
here and get stuck mine eyes
[Music]
you